hello everyone and welcome to another
most interesting game from the Sun we
see this tournament it's a wonder lien
versus Anton horrible we already seen
one game where laying the feet of a
silly when choking around 8 this is a
game from round 9 now he faces the
leader of the tournament Anton horrible
who drew his game against Chucky and
this I don't know I haven't seen
obviously all the games but this one is
just it's just insane so I do hope you
enjoy it now without further ado let's
check it out Leon with the white pieces
opens with E for now we have C 5 core
above goes for them for the Sicilian
defense but Knight the C 3 now a
leonov's further for the closed Sicilian
we have d6 and Bishop to b5 check Knight
d7 Corriveau blocks and now a 4 we have
knife to f6 and now a 6 push sorry first
F for a 6 pushing the bishop back Bishop
to c4 and now e 6 and here we already
have a position that has only been
enriched reached once where d3 was
played sorry where Quinta e 2 was played
but here D 3 is played and it is already
as of a move 7 that we have a completely
new game so let's see how it continues
core above goes for Bishop to e7 I know
you think maybe our corabeth's profile
photo here is a bit weird but it's
really it's a new photo of him by
Lennart Otis so I do hope you enjoy it
and it he really has big hair so it's
really hard to find one where you can
fit his hair inside of the profile photo
and here he's like this so it nicely
fits all the other photos if you if you
find any new like from 2019 they just
don't fit he has like massive hair but
ok Bishop to e7 with Knight to f3 and we
have castles by Cordova Valley and also
castles and b6 now preparing the fee and
key to the light square Bishop quinta II
1 now the Queen can come to g3 the dark
square Bishop can be perhaps
fianchettoed b3 Bishop here so the
bishop pair will be nicely nicely
pointing at the black King Bishop the b7
and now Russia back to b3 yeah just a
safer Square for the bishop also if d5
comes it will not come with a temple
the bishop so you can just advance with
E 5 if you want to keep the central
closed we've roped the c8 and now II
five asking black what do you do want to
do here they wanna play D characters and
allow me to semi open my F file so nice
that EA a bike or above and now Bishop
the b2 so probably the knight will move
and then the bishop can come to c3 that
to be used as an attack against the
black ink we have g6 black might have
some ideas of Riemann overing the 997
perhaps the f5 but also it serves as
additional protection from white pushing
f5 but incredibly this is exactly what
lien does and we've reached the position
from the thumbnail he pushes f5 he opens
up this dark square diagonal so the
bishop can be used to just start
detecting but also you will be able in
the future to do some nice rock lifting
maybe the Queen will be able to join the
attack not for the moment but a very
interesting point sacrifice if you ask
the computer the engine will say it's a
bad move you know don't don't play it
but some of the greatest attacks ever
will you know at least - 2 - 3
evaluation so that's besides the point
and you do have to capture you cannot
allow he captures a F captures on e6
since the e6 pawn is attacked twice now
and you cannot attack capture would be e
pawn because of e6000 I twill like
White's position is definitely worth the
sacrificed pawn so after f5 we have G
captors on f5 carbo is not afraid to
open up his G file and now it's time to
see what a lien had in store for him he
captures on d6 with Knight captures on
d6 and now Knight to e2 so what what
this means is that the bishop can now
come to c3 not abused and this beautiful
diagonal so core above now being of
material decides he wants to eliminate
as many attackers as possible Bishop
captures an f3 rook captures and now
Knight the Knights the e5 attacking the
rook and if rook g3 the knight can then
just block the check with Knight to g6
that was the point
rook the h3 instead and now see
or taking care of the light square
bishop you don't want it you know just
eyeing your your king like that and
Bishop back to a2 we have C captures and
III C captures and III and Bishop to f6
now black now against control of this
diagonal Bishop the c3 white of course
once the counter that bishop and just
knights the g6 offering a trade of dark
square Bishop C which would also
activate blacks Queen but of course
Liang isn't interested we have Queen to
d2 with the idea of just Queen to h6
followed by Queen to h7 mate and you
have to be very careful here you could
defend it with f4 but Bishop to g5 is
more precise so this is what core above
does Queen back to d1 and now Knight the
I ate the night is now coming to g7 and
from g7 the knight will be able to
support the advancement of the pawn to
h5 so you will not have to worry about
any ideas like Queen infiltrating while
being supported by the rook we have
Knight the d4 Lina's the idea is now he
wants to get the knight to f3 to kick
away the bishop from at g5 and then
again will reintroduce this threat of
Queen d2 to h6 to h7 mate Knight g7 as
planned and the knight to f3 pushing the
dark square Bishop back Russia back to
f6 and now Queen to d2 again with the
threat Queen h6 to h7 mate Corrib of
Defense with h5 now the knight nicely
guards the h5 pawn and now rook to f1
allying brings another attacker into the
game for the moment it's not really
attacking anything but there is no way
to improve the position further so rook
to e8 now with ideas of maybe advancing
the e pawn but Bishop to c4 and here the
d3 pawn is protected once more you are
also kind of preventing b5 but not
really here Cordoba finds a very nice
tactic he plays Bishop captures and c3b
captures and c3 this strengthens White's
Center but it also allows b5 so this is
something very very useful for black a
character say characters and now you
cannot capture with the bishop because
of Queen b6 check picking up the bishop
on b5 so instead the bishop goes
back to a2 and now Queen to a5 attacking
the the c3 pawn twice so what do you do
here it's not all that not all that easy
for example if you go nice to d4 to try
and trade pawns here black can just go
Queen b6 in the night and after King
each one just before and you will not be
able to to capture anything since the
night will be hanging so after Queen to
a5 liyan finds another way to continue
the attack but it requires for him to
give up more material he plays Bishop to
b1 we have Queen captures and c3 core
above earned that pawn and he's ready to
advance his past beep on the victory and
now Queen to h6 and now well Leon will
try whatever he can to create all sorts
of threats here we have rook to c7 core
above brings another defender to the
seventh rank and now rook to g3 and the
Queen back to f6 so now his idea is I'm
just gonna push the beep on to victory
we have d4 lien creates an outpost on e5
for the night also prevents black from
black from pushing d5 we have worked the
c3 now you cannot move the Knight to e5
since well you will lose a very
important attacker here so look the g5
and already you can see that the black
Queen doesn't really have all that many
squares yes the Queen cannot move to e7
and e8 but that's pretty much it those
are not very useful squares for
defending so core Bob starts advancing
the pawn just before we have Knights the
e5 by link and notice that you cannot
move the knight if you move the knight
you just lose the Queen here so b3 core
above continues advancing his pawn
we have ripped a d1 rook to d1 I don't
really see what's what's rook d1 I I
really I really doubt it's something
well the rogue d3 not really I think
it's a waiting move now just to see what
black will play as it doesn't really
introduce any threats
but then again white is unable to
produce in any more threats so here just
be to bike or above and now comes well
you just if you just wait
the Siwon is coming so here we have
night captures ng 6f captures and g6 and
now look at verse and g6 so the queen is
under attack
you can't move with the Queen away too
far otherwise you're getting made it so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the best move for white
sorry for black while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and finding such a well we could say
it's a root lift but it's really not
since the rock is already on c3 but
still congratulations on finding it and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's rope the c1 you have to give
up the Queen for the moment if you try
Queen f7 then a white just plays rook to
g3 he offers offers a rook trade and now
rook c1 doesn't really work because both
the rook and the Queen already guard the
C 1 square so here you would kind of let
the white of the hook just a little so
instead look the c1 this is what kora
both played and it is the strongest move
so now the point is if you trade that
captures then black has the the decision
to Queen captures and g6 Queen captures
just one capture son c1 with Czech king
of two now you're gonna go Queen B to
check if the King goes back so you can
pick up the bishop with check and if
King's you three or just pick it up and
you are up two pieces of course
completely winning so after this rook to
g6 move we have rooked the c1 at which
we already played but now rook captures
on f6 so this is what a lien went for
but now rook captures and e1 would check
King f2 and the rook captures on b1 so
for the moment Elian gives up a queen
but the threat is rook F 1 Czech
followed by just promoting to a queen
after the King captures and black will
just be up a piece so here King g3
preventing rook F 1 check but now look
the c1 again the thread is just want to
be 1 check and it was in this position
on move 43 that a wonderly and resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here just to demonstrate if rook g6
threatening mate just rook to e7
there's no no more moves here you could
continue it let's say you try something
like Queen g5 you attack the rook but to
then black has a very nice tag that you
just
one queen and after you pick up the rook
then f4 check is deadly not only can you
win the rook but you don't even need to
win the roof if King captures on f4
you're gonna go Queen f5 check King to
e3 and now the White King is in the
mating net King D - you're gonna go
Queen b3 check King you want we need to
recheck and now wherever you go it's
just made after rook to c1 so point
pointless to continue which of course
Leah knows and after this
rook to see one move he resigned the
game Corrib of continued here we have I
prepare that in the standings there you
have it let me just improve that a
little bit
those are these are core above opponents
as you can see he won the tournament
without a without a single loss so
that's seven wins and three draw so
incredibly impressive and as you can see
he started with six out of six then
after six out of six
a draw with Vasily when Chuck and the
vasila Dhirubhai lee then a victory in
round Hannigan's to wonder link and then
in last round he drew against a German
Grand Master now under a Simon and that
was enough to claim first place with
eight and a half points the only player
with eight and a half points with other
players eight and well I think Chuck in
the end finished with seven points but
yeah incredibly impressive and once
again a quarter both shows his class and
and shows that he he can basically win
any tournament in any time format
against anyone so very very interested
to see what what new surprises
Corvo has in store for us and yeah I
would like to thank a cool of chess pop
for a contributor to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate that I
received a book today
aha sorry here it is it's called a Supes
wand I received it from a subscriber
from mr. Vesely know which it says took
swung the way you pronounce it in
creation so I don't know why that is
I'm gonna find out when I read the book
it's about well basically as he he
mentioned in his letter it's about the
1914 tournament in some computer book
that we've already covered on this
channel
during capablanca Oscar Rubinstein and
the whole gang but it's not really about
that like it's more of a fiction like
some players are who they are in real
life and some aren't I'm gonna go
through the book and I'm really looking
forward to us so thank you for that mr.
mr. Leslie no itch I really I'm really
going to enjoy this one so that's pretty
much it like I said I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check to my
previous videos here and that's it thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day